ABCs of AI G is for Glam not that kind
oh
generalist language model is a large
multitask language model that uses a
mixture of experts Moe architecture Moe
is a type of neural network that divides
the model into smaller sub models called
experts Each of which is specialized for
a different task the experts are then
combined to form a single model that can
perform multiple tasks it can be used to
determine things like whether a sentence
is true or false or generate texts like
poems code and letters sound familiar
that's because Bard Google's AI chatbot
is a Glam Glam is a sparse model which
means that there's a gating layer that
based on input data sparsely activates
the experts this can lead to significant
Savings in computation and memory check
out some other cool stuff related to
glim in the comments what other AI
topics do you want to know more about on
the next episode of